you've probably seen these make ten
thousand dollar a month in 30 days scam
businesses marketing all over the
Internet and on the same degree you've
probably seen Harvard market and say you
might maybe graduate from Harvard and
that's the only promise they make and
you can pay us 250 000 a year and so
what's the difference between this
clearly scam business and this
incredibly legit 100 plus year old
business it turns out there's only four
things and I apply this strategy in
building acquisition.com that only buys
companies that's all we do this is how
we do it there are multiple levels of
legitimacy for education on one side you
have Harvard most people don't call
Harvard a scam but they fundamentally
sell education and on this side you've
got a guy who tells you how to start an
ATM business and promises that you're
going to make a hundred thousand dollars
a day in five seconds they both sell
education and on the scam index why is
this one maxed out and this one's a zero
number one Harvard turns people down I
applied for Harvard for 10 times
rejected if every single person who
apply eyes to work with you and the only
requirement to become a customer of
yours is a credit card and a pulse ding
ding ding red flag number one most
people probably aren't qualified to
become customers and if you define a
qualified lead as somebody who has the
highest likelihood of success with your
program or service or education then you
should have screening metrics for who is
not a good fit it's more likely that
they'll be upset leave you bad reviews
call you a scam which you can easily
avoid number one by selling qualified
customers only number two is that
Harvard doesn't give income expectations
they don't say become a Harvard graduate
make money tomorrow there's a delay
between when you start and when you
actually even graduate and get the
endorsement of their brand which to be
fair is really what Harvard sells is the
brand endorsement that you get to put on
yourself the second thing is that
instead of giving testimonials of
students on income I graduated Harvard
and I got my first job at 185 000 at
Goldman Sachs you don't see that
anywhere on their site but what they
will publish is is data and this is
[__] huge if you do not track your
customer success metrics meaning when
someone buys what percent of them
succeed at 30 60 90 12 months what are
the averages for whatever the thing that
you educate them on if you track the
data then you don't add any
sensationalism to what you're reporting
Harvard publishes what the top 20
percent with the average with the median
person gets and what industries their
graduates go into because that's data
they're not setting false expectations
and they're not saying this is what you
can expect in six weeks They're saying
four years ago these people started and
today they graduated and this is what
they got the highlights that they have
at Harvard are not the income but the
experience and the network and the
relationships and the character
development now if you're thinking to
yourself man it would be harder to sell
people that way
but if you do it that way and you only
let in really good people what do you
think happens you start to develop a
brand for example I was having this
discussion with Jacob my neighbor
because he was saying he was considering
starting a sales School whether he does
that or not at some point in the future
is irrelevant but I said if you were
going to start one then you want to be
legit about it because you see everybody
and their mother has a sales school
right now because they start selling
High ticket they immediately make 20
grand a month and they start a course on
how to make 20 grand a month that's a
high ticket closer if you want to be
legit about it what you would do is you
would give tons of content away for free
this is pillar number three you can
monetize the education itself you can
sell education but I think the smart
move and if you've consumed any of my
stuff is that you give away the secrets
you sell the implementation take all the
content you would normally sell as your
course and give it all away for free so
if I were selling the ability to sell
then I would give away the course as
content through all the different
platforms I pass we could and the
implementation would be let me listen to
your sales calls give you feedback in
real time and then monitor your
performance over that period so that you
become a salesperson pillar number four
Harvard doesn't graduate everyone some
people fail and the reason for that is
because Harvard wants to maintain their
brand because what they say is sure
Johnny graduated from Harvard with a 1-6
GPA now he was smart enough to get in
but through the four years we saw that
he didn't have some of these other
character traits so I was telling Jacob
if you want to be smart about it number
one you would just show the data number
two you would probably not accept ninety
percent of people who want to be sales
people because you could immediately
tell in the interview just like Harvard
does that you're probably not going to
be a good salesperson so it's easier to
find people who have proclivity for
sales and then just get them this much
better and then endorse them but before
you have the endorsement you still rank
order them on who you think has
succeeded the best and have the
possibility that someone pays and does
not get your endorsement because that is
how you long term maintain the brand and
so let's play this out how could we get
100 of people who graduate from my thing
to be the best salespeople first thing
is we pick people who are naturally good
at sales second thing is cut out the
people who are not third we set
expectations that are only Based on data
and the remainder of our testimonials
and stories are based on the experiences
of people who've gone through our system
or programmer implementation I establish
far more demand for my service than I
have Supply so that I can keep my prices
High by generating more content that is
better than everyone else's paid stuff
you maintain thought leadership and all
they do is copy what you have and
everyone else can then make a judgment
wait their free stuff isn't as good as
your free stuff so then your paid stuff
must be better than their paid stuff
that's the natural logic that the
marketplace will always do let's say you
did it and you had a really high
standard and you've only been making
content for let's say a year now if
you're like wait only a year yeah it
takes time to build big ship so if you
build it for a year and let's say you
only got 25 people to graduate but
they're all killers Savages what do you
think is going to happen to the
companies that they go get jobs at you
got any more now you have even more
Demand on both sides what do you think
is going to happen to the Friends of
those people who start making twice with
the industry averages for sales guys
because they're that much better their
top 20 top 5 sales guys rather than just
run of the mail sales guys their friends
are gonna be like if I'm gonna make
three hundred thousand dollars a year
rather than the industry average sales
guy making 60 I make five times the
income how much more valuable is this
one-year education well we know Harvard
charges people 250 000 for their four
years so for a year you could probably
charge a lot because you have the data
to support the fact that one you don't
let everyone in two when people graduate
you also have a rank order is that an
education business abso [__] lutely
is it a scam in no possible [__] way